le caire mais aussi suez et alexandrie
l'egypte a donc été le théâtre
aujourd'hui d'une manifestation sans
équivalent depuis plus de 30 ans un
soulèvement historique le 25 janvier
onze jours après la chute de ben ali en
tunisie l'égypte et gagné à son tour par
l'atmosphère révolutionnaire du
printemps arabe
accablé par la corruption l'état
policier du chômage les égyptiens sorte
par milliers dans les rues du pays pour
défier leur président notre message
tient en un mot président moubarak parte
et nous voulons plus de vous ne
supportons plus votre système de
gouvernement
hosni moubarak au pouvoir depuis 1981
répond par la force le 28 janvier une
nouvelle manifestation au caire est
matée dans le sang par la police
soixante-huit personnes trouvent la mort
parfois la violence surgit à quelques
mètres des caméras de télévision au sol
un manifestant re soit un massage
cardiaque de fortune plus loin
cette jeune femme vient de recevoir un
projectile en pleine tête devant ses
compagnons désemparés
le soir l'insurrection a définitivement
gagné le centre de la capitale tandis
que les chars de l'armée pénètre dans la
ville l'armée montre ses muscles mais
choisit finalement la neutralité et
n'empêche pas la poursuite des
manifestations contre moubarak
on ne veut plus de toi hurle la foule
autour de la place tahrir épicentre de
la contestation se croiser les
différentes composantes de la révolution
des jeunes membres de la classe moyenne
et adeptes des réseaux sociaux
on veut juste l'egypte libre à les
classes populaires déterminée elle aussi
à renverser moubarak
nous on n'a même pas de quoi manger et
lui il veut gagner du temps on va
continuer enfin les frères musulmans qui
rejoignent dans nombres la révolution en
marche le 1er février une manifestation
voit défiler plus d'un million de
personnes dans les rues du caire
alors le lendemain moubarak lâche t
spire sur la place tahrir au milieu du
tumulte des hommes à dos de cheval ou de
chameaux armés de bâtons et de fouet ils
fendent la foule comme pour l'inciter à
se disperser en scène impressionnante
mais inutile les révolutionnaires sont
maîtres du terrain les jours passent et
sur la place tahrir les manifestants
déterminés répète la promesse de tenir
jusqu'à la chute du dictateur
nous on restera c'est lui qui va partir
enfin le 11 février
la nouvelle se propage dans l'allégresse
générale vous êtes sûr c'est pas une
rumeur
non non ils l'ont dit à la télévision
quelques minutes plus tôt le vice
président omar souleiman annoncé à la
télévision que le président moubarak
quittait ses fonctions et confié le
pouvoir à l'armée
selon amnistie internationale 846 civils
sont morts durant les 17 jours de la
révolution égyptienne
[Musique]